mein name ist khan herzlich willkommen
hier heute meine lieben freunde zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal hier seht es
bereits schon im hintergrund wir
befinden uns hier vom rewe center in
köln und meine lieben freunde was ihr
auch wisst dass die lupe 23 draußen ist
von daher habe ich mir gedacht wir
machen heute ein bisschen schabernack
ihrem rewe dafür werde ich allerdings
nicht so normal rumlaufen die ich sonst
wohl auch für sondern ich habe einen
lauf maske vorbereitet weil ich bin
laufen dann wird es noch mehr deutlich
den anderen leuten
ziel des heutigen videos wird sein dass
ich mit dieser lauf maske bei lauf
befindet sich auch auf der lu kapitza 3
wird sie wohl auch zwiebeln ich werde
mir im rewe die sieben käsesorten
zusammen suchen die auch auf den luca
pizza drauf sind und zwar emmentaler
gouda oder mascarpone ricotta große
diesem moment lücken
hier ist laut
zu wissen ich habe noch nie so großen
supermarkt gesehen ganz normale einkaufs
für mich wo ist denn käse ich kenne
diesen käse der so eingepackt ist
zweiter vor wenn die käsetheke haben
deshalb sei es ihr könnt ihr einfach
sagen ich will diese verschiedenen
sorten haben ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
wenn ich zum wir also gerade haben auf
jeden fall schonmal gefundene liebe
freunde der käsesorten drauf ist das
heißt wir haben noch emmentaler jeder
mal das inventar das gefordert
[Musik]
ich finde nicht mehr
siehst du noch was
mozzarella die sache dass krieg obamas
kann das in eine andere liga ich glaube
das ist ja nicht unbedingt wie
geschichte irgendwo im normalen einlauf
hier zwischen den leuten ein schmied ich
finde mich überhaupt nicht bescheuert
ist wie immer ich finde nichts mehr
[Musik]
jeder weiß dass der song crazy käse dass
er hier nicht einfach drin ist es ist ja
eh schon irgendwie so dass wir hier mit
einer kamera rumlaufen alle leute so ein
bisschen gucken dann habe ich halt auch
noch so
[Musik]
sauce käse welche nicht so auch in
bestimmten käse welche suchen sie aber
der ist letztendlich ein tiefkühl
ich suche jedes mal wenn sie den
gefunden haben
das ist eine riesen peter versuche ich
ja im jahr davor
herrlich
[Musik]
tschuldigung haben sie jeder mag es ist
egal
dann brauche ja mascarpone und ricotta
ich okay dann schaut man danke es
überall helfen mehr soziale kontakte
ich verzweifle geraten das tempo ist ja
auch noch komplett
hier muss ich dafür nicht nur wenige
minuten später
das ist ja der abzuwarten sind das sind
sachen aus dem krater drei die fenster
nicht mehr im supermarkt ist der da
kommt wissen wir dass so viele
käsesorten gibt ich bin verzweifelt ich
hab alles da ist ja der wahnsinn wie
damals auch mit einem status wir
brauchen jetzt nur noch drei käsesorten
also werden jetzt die gerade auch ohne
luca pizza 3 tatsächlich gefunden im
revier von daher schon mal hinten drauf
jeder mal haben wir in diesem käse box
drin modell war emmentaler haben wir wir
haben gouda und mozzarella
ich hab doch keinen job ich bin nun laut
der seinen käse so okay leute also den
keller da bin ich die ganze zeit daran
vorbeigelaufen den haben es tatsächlich
auch hier das erwartete brauchen jetzt
nur noch ricotta nur noch ricotta und
mascarpone ach du grüne neune gelaufen
ich hoffe jetzt 400 vorbei ohne haben
wir auch
[Musik]
wir haben wir haben es fügt sich das an
das heißt auf der lu kapitza drei alt
ist der absolute wahnsinn
aha da fällst du bist ja ich einfach mal
überlegen in diesem karton ist das alles
sind also nicht das alles aber von
halben so ein bisschen ein bisschen auf
qualität gefordert
haben sie schon gegessen
nein nicht das ist mein standard outfit
ja ich glaube dann auch feiern und weil
ich eine gute idee für karneval gewesen
wann braucht 950 arbeiter wie ein
bisschen verkaufen zu können
meine damen und herren gerne zitiert die
erste partie für meine these hier
beiseite warum sollte die pizza bianca
nur ins regal liegen
let's think outside box ja fisch frau
kein mensch also ich finde solche witze
darüber liegen
was haben wir hier das ja alles gut von
bern wieder mitarbeiter
wir kommen immer mehr mitarbeiter gerade
deswegen
wir nehmen unseren käse mal und hier
noch eine pizza mit und dann gehen wir
mal eben zur kasse
so hatte pfizer leuten genau haben wir
ja meine lieben freunde hätten regel
mitarbeiterinnen von unten haben jetzt
gesagt ich kann mir tatsächlich direkt
auch hier eine pizza machen hier direkt
mit dem ofen den sie haben deswegen
würde ich jetzt einfach sagen das hier
sind die mengen zutaten die auf demokrat
mit 23 draußen also wir haben ja die
lieben verschiedene käsesorten und wir
haben den lauf den ich mir gerade schon
ausgezogen habe was wenn man daran denkt
auch erkennen können
daher würde ich sagen wir machen die pcs
einfach mal auf und werden die in den
ofen backen dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder sehr jung ist vergangen meine
lieben freunde und wie ihr seht ihr
schon das ist ja der absehbaren und
filmer noch unter dem licht dann ist ja
ein mensch und das habe ich halt noch
nicht gefrühstückt perfekt übrigens ich
es auch wenn ich mir die zu hause mache
eigentlich immer vor dem karton selbst
weil die pizzeria tag einfach zu groß
ist ist für meine teller in der wohnung
karlovic mit ihm freunde die ju kapitza
drei hier ist jetzt fertig das mit dem
käse das ist einfach das ist einfach
geil diesmal noch ordentlich heiß auf
jeden fall nämlich erst die spitze
das ist ihr job die 35 pizza oder so die
ich von gestern
ja meine lieben freunde der anstelle
wird das heutige video dann auch beenden
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen dass wir
heute hier beim revier so ein bisschen
unfug getrieben haben wer macht das
video gefallen hat das ist auf jeden
fall einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da schreibt nicht einmal uns in die
kommentare
die neue ducati 23 schon gegessen habt
uns 1 jahr wie sie euch schmeckt schaut
doch gern in der infobox unten vorbei
denn dort ist rewe verlinkt da könnt ihr
auch gerne vorbeischauen und erst jetzt
noch auf eine ewigkeit später alles was
sie bisher gesehen habt in diesem video
haben wir heute morgen um 9 uhr im rewe
aufgenommen ich hab das video gerade
geschnitten ich bin jetzt gerade bei der
hälfte im schnitt allerdings ist mir
gerade aufgefallen
luca du musst unbedingt noch ans ende
irgendwie so ein video reinpacken
einfach weil ich mich gerade da was
heißt schlecht fühle aber ich bin so
unendlich dankbar und ich bringe das
viel zu selten glaube ich euch gegenüber
so richtig auf falls das gericht in
deutschland ich mag das nicht so gern
wenn youtuber so voll lang lagern und
blabla so aber ich weiß nicht ich fühle
mich einfach gerade danach und möchte
euch einfach sagen ich bin ich unendlich
dankbar dafür dass ich meine träume zu
verwirklichen kann
klar einer gewissen form ist es nur eine
pizza die ich jetzt raus gebracht habe
und es ist jetzt auch schon die dritte
pizza die ich zusammen mit co star
bewusst so gemacht habe das bedeutet mir
echt viel ich weiß nicht ob ich das
gerade richtig rüberbringen aber ich
wollte einfach danke sagen so nicht nur
jetzt vier für die pizza und für die
coole rewe korb und alles mögliche
sondern so allgemein dass sich so dank
euch ja das machen kann ich hoffe euch
schmeckt di luca pizza 3 bzw
in erster linie hoffe ich erst mal dass
sie bei euch in der nähe auch wirklich
verfügbar ist weil wie bereits gesagt
jeder mag leiter kann selbst entscheiden
welches produkt er bei sich in die
tiefkühltruhe legt also ich hoffe dass
ihr sie probieren könnte und ich hoffe
dass ihr euch schmeckt und
ja noch mal danke for everything tschüss
[Musik]